47 seconds of logos backwards end school
spelled with a k how old is Andy's
supposed to be in this movie again
because unless it's six he should know
better either that or he made all these
box buildings as a six year old and is
still playing with them years later
which is just saddens imaginations
computer animation baby collects another
soul if you look at directly in the eyes
also in this giant ass two-story house
with only one adult
why the hell does Andy have to share a
bedroom with the baby sister does mom
have like three separate crafting rooms
Andy is addictive woody this household
has a Super Nintendo system but
apparently no games to play with it also
Andy has a Super Nintendo but would
still rather play with woody dolls
probably because of the lack of games
I'm guessing unlike most kids Andy
actually closes the door to his room a
good thing too or else the toys I'd have
to wait until no one was in the house to
come to life pull my string the birthday
party's today with the sheer number of
toys strewn around this house and
Woody's apparent wealth of logic and
street smarts there was no way he would
get the date of the birthday party wrong
overly dexterous plastic pig not only
toss his coin in the air without
opposable thumbs but also lands it
perfectly straight up so it goes into
his piggy bank slot how did mr. Potato
Head even know Picasso's work to make
the joke in the first place either slink
has all these checker pieces set up on
the wrong color or else and I really
hesitate to say this but I may have been
playing checkers wrong my whole life
did the pieces not go on the black
squares sorry John Lasseter no one is
reading to suppose a 200 page book
concerning your 1988 oscar-winning short
tin toy nice try animators scene does
not contain a cartoon lapdance
also the idea of toys having sex there's
still plastic right it opens up so many
questions about lubricants and chafing
and whether these toys were built
anatomically correct I forgot I was
watching a kids movie yeah they can hear
you and possibly Andy and his mom can
hear you too and everybody outside that
open window as well a minute ago what he
needed the speaker to move away so there
wouldn't be feedback now I can stand as
close as he wants take a look
those presents what if Andy would walk
in the bedroom right now huh do you
people have any idea the emotional
scarring you'd cause if he saw all this
what he doesn't order the soldiers out
to do recon for another 45 seconds or so
so they literally have no way to know if
Andy's approaching but there's still way
out of position none of the neighbors
see this stuff I'm not the only person
in America who spies on his neighbor's
wheat his totally solid plastic
binoculars actually work and tees it
none for the surprise buzz lightyear
later Andy's gifts would be proof that
he's unloved these two always open the
closet door without using the handle
Buzz Lightyear to Star Command come in
Star Command do all toys start out
thinking they're real or is Buzz unique
in that regard did all the other toys
have a similar coming to grips with it
experience more buzz is in the typical
I'm a toy pose here but how did it
deluded toys such as himself ever learn
to do this how do they know not to say
anything to humans when you really
thought for a fact that he was a Space
Ranger
you know what Bravo for simulating the
passage of time with the shadows that
just blows my mind this is a hilarious
moment when both thinks he's gonna die
but you're telling me this is the first
time since his arrival that his helmet
has come off Andy has had enough time to
change his posters and linens and ditch
woody for a new favorite toy but he
hasn't pressed all the buttons yet a
real little boy pushed all those buttons
back as soon as the gift was open every
single piece of exploded combat Carl
debris flies straight at our main
characters instead of any of the other
directions in the 360-degree spectrum
that it could have flown
somehow this nuns from the car knocks
all these tacks out of the corkboard I
see Buzz Lightyear went to the
Prometheus school running away from
things Buzz Wilhelm this is why this
toys come to life while humans are gone
thing would never work I got bailed out
here only because Andy yelled down to
his mom wide open window is still left
wide open when family leaves for pizza
planet I'm assuming they're going to
Pizza Planet at a decent hour but they
go to a filling station that is
practically deserted and a surrounding
town that looks totally deserted
also Andy always closes his door at home
but he leaves the Vans door wide open
while they pump the gas and presumably
go into the store allowing not only Buzz
and Woody to exit but for any hobo to
sneak into the van also it took like
five seconds for Andy's mom to put the
nozzle in the gas tank start fueling and
completely leave the gas pumps so that
Woody and Buzz could have their fight
and no one could see it okay not to be
an asshole or anything but once you're
out of the view of the driver you don't
need to sit still do you Woody and Buzz
argue loudly so that any truck driver
could hear luckily no one does
conveniently the Chucky Cheese like
Pizza Planet also delivers and just
happens to drive to this abandoned gas
station where I heard a guy got murdered
that one time
monstrous stack of pizzas allows buzz
the perfect cover also isn't this plan
totally over once he grabs the pizzas
and delivers them to whomever he's gonna
see him when he takes the pizzas or when
he comes back right pizza delivery guy
leaves his pizza sleeves in the truck to
keep buzzes plan working Pizza Planet
serve as a 128 ounce mega goal also
burgers Buzz and Woody demonstrate they
can somehow see out of these containers
by freezing in position well before the
kids run by then demonstrate they can't
see out of the containers by running
into each other
Sid just happens to be at the Pizza
Planet because evil always lurks at
Pizza themed restaurants - what better
place
Sid puts one quarter in and gets a prize
on the first Pole this claw works unlike
any other in the history of the prize
machine universe I'm sorry sit doesn't
win this one there's no way evil
character has at least one light source
that is a single bulb swinging free from
a chain cliche here's where buzz finally
learns this is just a toy but one thing
is off about this it's this room the
adult sleeping and the recliner is
obviously into hunting with a duck
wallpaper and the deer head mounted on
the wall there cans strewn about that
say Cola and root beer but we should
take these to suggest alcohol not soft
drinks there's a wrench used to turn on
the power of the TV and a coat hanger
used as an antenna a forlorn guitar
propped up against it it's a poor family
possibly a failed musician what program
is this down in the dumps adult watching
we're a Buzz Lightyear commercial
targeted at kids would be playing the
string of Christmas lights that what he
was hiding in had disappeared in this
shot and magically reappear in the shot
how would you even begin to get back
into position and put this away in time
if someone walked into the room right
now well he's been gone for like not
even a day yet and everything falls
apart
that would be an impossible throw for a
human to make even dude perfect would
need like 20 or 30 takes but they're
cannibals
that's great but how does it explain
this to himself when he sees that
magically fixed toys it sure wasn't his
parents that did it and he fall asleep
and stay asleep while still holding
something like this hat would it drop to
the floor the moment he started to drip
off
okay moving you cheated just 15 seconds
ago buzz couldn't even look at his foot
why not making the standard noises that
accompany the movement of hard plastic
toy action figures but then so we can
have a little wee surprise buzz is
suddenly able to stand up and walk away
and climb up on top of the crate when
I'm making a single sound with a heavy
ass rocket taped to his back since alarm
clock goes off at 7 a.m. which he set
the previous night at 8:25 that means it
took roughly 11 hours for Woody to start
asking buzz to help while he was under
the crate but the hell was he doing
before then toys don't need to sleep
okay let's move either Sid is taking way
too long to launch his Firecracker buzz
or these misfit toys and woody put
together a fairly elaborate plan way too
fucking quickly Sid sister heard the
doorbell but not the skateboard full of
toys going down the stairs what he waits
much longer than he needs to in order to
distract Sid I mean that fuse is
practically lit already wind up from
comes out of the mud completely clean
I'm okay with talking sentient toys in a
movie I really am but I'm not okay with
talking senta toys that can run fast
enough to catch up to a truck moving at
even the slowest speed toys plastic
fingers have a stronger grip than a
dog's jaws in other words ya know Woody
is puppy chow Andy's family moved
without sealing their boxes well thank
goodness for that conveniently timed and
extremely long red light this is cute
and all but you can clearly see that
while wittiest beings fun he only has
the accelerator pressed on the
controller and nothing is touching the
steering wheel abortion so RNC's should
not be spinning in circles right now
also Arcee is a talking sentient Tony
like the rest of them there are times in
this movie where he freely moves in his
own will so how does this work does the
remote control supersede our seas own
women as a thinking toy why doesn't the
remote controller have its own separate
sentient personality as a jump button on
that controller to this guy in the blue
car must be flipping out seeing a
remote-control car driving to other toys
toward a moving van with a bunch of
other toys cheering them in the back
whoever inscribing this truck doesn't
notice this
ah Disney didn't we get enough of that
song the year before this came out
I'm sorry slink but in my experience
with your sort of toy you're basically
worthless forever now you'd make a
decent instrument for a strangulation or
accidental maiming of oneself and that's
about it the rocket wow that match never
fell out during all that hell I'm kind
of surprised the rocket didn't fall off
but the match I think is long gone and
don't get me started on Woody's hat
either people hunt this is where I stop
and ask you to ponder one thing if Sid
had never tortured woody then Woody and
Buzz would never be able to put this
plan together and be returned to Andy
which means the movie sort of saying
torture is a necessary evil and I'm okay
with that
and I am NOT okay with that the street
was dead empty for like forever just a
second ago Andy asks no questions why
the two toys he was looking for suddenly
show up in a box right next to it
let's go home and blegh
Code Red repeat did you order the Code
Red god damn right I did
what's that button do I'll show you
flying with the dead elven on our back
flight guidance we're getting awfully
close to center here where's watch that
middle gimbal we don't want you coming
off in space look for them use them run
away the goddamn gimbals i don't like
confrontations I got your name I got
your ass you will look well you will not
cry what do you say I get someone else
to watch the Sheep tonight oh oh oh